vas y ma la marque ce que vous appelez
veille
bien sûr très bien je mens cette
séquence par un compliment
un petit compliment que j'ai écrit
vraiment pour vous connais ça fait déjà
un bail chez vous on a mis tout votre
voix votre voyais mais même si vous avez
fait bye bye je vous le dis tout net
mais tu vas y estime à y changer
m
[Musique]
comment vous l'avez expliqué cette
espèce d'amour que les français avaient
pour vous je pense que c'est parce que
je fais une bonne blague
est ce que vous savez pourquoi les
girafes ont des langues ou non parce
qu'elle pue des pieds
ben voilà voyez c'est tout le glamour de
miss france et c'est ça quand même parce
que moi j'en ai j'avais une de vos
phrases et je voulais vérifier si
c'était vrai quand on vous demande quel
est votre animal préféré on reste dans
les animaux vous demande vous dites quoi
mais j'ai dit une fois mais je me suis
dit mais c'est génial quad une saveur
sans de la cuisson et voilà donc pas
peur d'eux comme politiquement correct
et pis la blague merci je donne à
ressentir est alors votre album
s'appelle good vibes et que selon le 7
février un nom il faudra être un petit
peu patient parce que franchement cet
album il fait du bien il devrait être
remboursé par la sécurité sociale votre
voix mais elle apaise mesure c'est un
bonheur vous reprenez une de mes
chansons préférées mais septième année
parce que moi j'étais gamine quand je
l'écouté cette chance à s'est pas quitté
basse à ça veut dire pourquoi tu t'en
vas et en fait ça m'a rappelé tellement
de souvenirs parce qu'en général quand
je drague un mec pas longtemps après je
lui dis pourquoi tu t'en par pascal il
part très près villedômer peut-être
qu'il va rechercher des génoises juillet
pour les petits matins jour au lendemain
et tout mais c'est sain non mais vous
connaissez partir chercher du pain au
chocolat
je savais que vous étiez une bonne
copine et que vous saviez leur remonter
le moral des gens alors vous avez dit si
je ne me mets pas à chanter mes proches
savent que je ne vais pas bien donc
j'espère que vous allez bien aujourd'hui
on va faire un petit un petit jeu de
questions réponses en chansons d'accord
j'ai eu je que je vous pose la question
et vous me répondez est ce qu'on peut
vous voir vénère vous semblait calme
comme la mer vous êtes 12 comme ma grand
mère dans son jardin d'hiver je suis pas
moi en colère
j'ai un sac les caractères si je me
retrouve en galère tu peux casser des
verts franchement est-ce que vous pensez
que n'importe qui peut devenir miss
france est ce que vous auriez des
conseils à me donner pour devenir miss
france en fait c'est pas je pense que
n'importe qui qui le veut vraiment
vraiment je veux vraiment alors vous
pourriez pas quand il ya des critères
quand même qu'ils sont qui sont
nécessaires tels que avoir moins de 25
ans parce que servette maquis est
vraiment vraiment très soutenu c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai c'est seul français
que à 26 ans on sait déjà qu'on peut pas
soutenir alors je dois dire que lâché 25
ans j'ai passé toute la journée et que
l'on m'a dit qu'il fallait qu'il soit
plein à 17 heures donc je me suis levé à
ces heures là ça c'est la vie semble ici
c'est ça oui mais ça doit être moi ça
doit être la fatigue accumulée des
dernières soirées où je me suis fait
plaisir
et alors vraiment le 7 février pour
l'instant vous pouvez déjà vous laisser
bercer par ce conte d'hiver parce que
c'est indécent
et puis ensuite vous allez voir vous
allez découvrir plein de facettes de vay
dans l'album good vibes
merci beaucoup